[Music]
I think one of the really scary and
overwhelming things about terrorism can
be the idea that it's this giant
boogeyman that is really difficult to
comprehend and is terrifying and comes
along in the night out of nowhere and
steals your family members or loved ones
away and for me my life's work has
really been understanding the small
logical puzzle pieces that when taken
together create that boogeyman so that
you can take it apart into manageable
pieces and actually begin to understand
what drives these inconceivable actions
so when you take this overwhelming
boogeyman of terrorism and you begin to
tease it apart based on the data and
look for patterns that turn up again and
again each time a terrorist plot is
planned in a different territory
throughout the historical data you begin
to notice patterns that might not seem
obvious to begin with so things like the
percentage beneath livable wage that a
border guard gets paid which of course
gives rise to the possibility of
accepting a bribe to let somebody just
sneak across the border or hand a
package to you if that bribe is the
difference between being able to feed
your kids that months or not it's a
pretty understandable small choice for
that individual actor and yet has given
rise to perhaps a terrorist act to being
able to take place even though the law
of the territory should have prevented
it another example would be the rate of
change of things like freedom of the
press or freedom of speech not the
scores themselves but the rate of change
which goes to the difficulty that
societies experience when they suddenly
open up and allow liberties that many of
the more traditional members of society
haven't been accustomed to in the past
there are strategies for taking
communities through those evolutions but
without those strategies in place it can
seem very jarring and we experience that
even in a mature democracy like ours
where when certain changes take place
quickly it can take portions of the
community
time to be comfortable with them and to
catch up in a political environment
another example would be the ratio of
hookah bars to madrasas and there you
begin to see you know tensions between
more traditional religious elements in
society and a younger demographic in
many countries where you have more than
50% in that youth demographic there's a
big cultural rift there that can often
give rise to lack of understanding or
the feeling that young people are not
being incorporated into society and need
some other outlet for for their feelings
of frustration and eventually rage
another really interesting one that we
see is how good machine translation is
for a local language so often we think
that libraries in in the olden days and
and now the provision of hardware and
internet access points can be a great
tool in the fight against extremism
all of a sudden young people in a given
area have access to the sum total of
human knowledge how great is that and
yet if the language that's spoken the
dialect in that region is not very well
translated by Google Translate or other
artificial intelligence programs then
really access to the Internet for the
majority of young people who don't
necessarily speak another language or
dialect is not terribly meaningful
because they're generally seeing sites
that for small dialects are actually
created in their vicinity and may not
offer perspectives that are particularly
different from what they're hearing
around them in a given day so there are
a number of these correlations and the
beauty you know my dad's an economist
and I grew up in a household that loved
throwing data around around the dinner
table and the beauty of data is that you
can look at huge sets across many
different time periods and geographies
and see patterns that emerge so starkly
that you can't ignore them these kinds
of inputs are really helpful in
understanding how regular human being
like you and me who grew up in different
environments subject to different inputs
could find themselves with different
perspectives about what's happening in
the world and eventually if their
perspectives go unheard
feel increasing frustration that
eventually can find its outlet in a
violent way well what one of the things
that I think is very interesting outside
of those just being intellectually
interesting one of the practical
applications of that kind of study is to
see where there are easy cheap efficient
ways to make a disproportionately big
impact in portions of the world where
instead of launching a kind of nebulous
multi-million dollar program that maybe
is not going to hit the milestones that
it's intending to hit you can go in with
very surgical and efficient programs and
make a disproportionately large impact
in the lives of the people living in
those regions
[Music]